the blast came in the early hours of
Monday morning daylight revealed the
damage at one of Russia's air bases not
far away from Moscow the defense
Ministry accusing Kiev of using drones
to attack the facilities although Russia
claimed some success in blunting the
strikes
Ukrainian uavs flying at low altitude
were intercepted by the air defense of
the Russian Aerospace forces
Russian officials say several servicemen
were killed in the explosions at
military bases near the cities of riazan
and Saratov
Kiev hasn't commented but if confirmed
it would be the deepest Ukrainian strike
in Russian territory since the start of
the war on the Ukrainian counterpunch
after weeks of Russian bombardment on
energy infrastructure the ukrainians are
being suffering a full scaled
bombardment from long-range Russian
Strike weapons drones missile against
their civilian targets and it would
boost Ukrainian morale to know that
they're also hitting Russian Target in
return
so it was probably a combination of
Ukraine always wanted to do this for you
strategic reasons and now they have an a
tactical window to do it
Ukraine was blamed for an attack on the
Kirsch bridge in Crimea less than two
months ago on Monday Russian State
television showed President Vladimir
Putin assessing the damage meanwhile his
forces continued to rain down missiles
across Ukraine some hit this Village in
zaparitia killing at least two people
and destroying property and further
strikes on critical infrastructure has
left many areas without electricity
Barbara angopa Al Jazeera